en este vídeo vamos a ver cómo encender
y apagar la cámara usando transistores y
también veremos cómo controlar la
función del disparador estamos usando
transistores
np n son transistores 2n 22 a y
resistencias de 10 kilos aquí conectamos
las resistencias de 10 kilos como lo
hicimos en el módulo de sonido en la
base o pin central de nuestros
transistores ahora cortamos nuestro
cable de núcleo sólido de cobre de
calibre 22 lo pelamos y lo vamos a
conectar en nuestro arduino lo colocamos
en el lugar donde unimos los pines 4 y 5
4 va a la energía y 5 al disparador
tenemos nuestros cables magnéticos que
van a los contactos de nuestros botones
para encender y apagar la cámara vamos a
quitar la cubierta la cara que cubre a
estos cables usando el borde sin filo de
nuestro cutter aquí es importante que
derrotemos el cable para quitar la
cubierta en la parte de atrás y a los
lados de cada cable ya que es muy fácil
que se nos olvide hacerlo y si dejamos
algo del aislante pues no tendremos una
conexión tan buena la laca es un
aislante más delgado y hace que estos
cables sean más fáciles de conectar con
nuestras conexiones de energía de
nuestros interruptores pero no son los
cables adecuados para usar en nuestra
tarjeta de prototipos porque el calibre
es muy pequeño y no va a quedarse en su
lugar en la tarjeta de prototipos así
que tenemos que unirlo a otro cable y es
un cable de conexión de calibre 22
torcemos el cable magnético alrededor
del cable de conexión y soldamos a ambos
cables juntos
debemos asegurarnos de que la soldadura
los cubra bien por todos lados para
tener una conexión sólida y para evitar
cortocircuitos vamos a colocar un tubo
de plástico que se encoge encima usamos
nuestras pinzas para dejar expuestos
unos 6 milímetros o un cuarto de pulgada
ahora usamos nuestra pistola de aire
caliente para encoger el plástico y que
envuelva bien la conexión y la proteja
ahora podemos doblar este cable y
colocarlo en su lugar que es del lado
izquierdo de nuestro transistor este
será nuestro lado emisor y ahora
pondremos nuestro lado receptor
raspamos la cobertura laqueada de nuevo
vamos a torcer lo alrededor de un cable
de conexión de calibre 22
los soldados en su lugar lo cubrimos
bien para tener una buena conexión y
nuevamente lo cubrimos con el plástico
que se encoge para evitar que haga
cortocircuito
conectamos esto del otro lado de nuestro
transistor justo aquí esto permitirá a
nuestro arduino enviar un voltaje
pequeño a nuestro transistor para
encender nuestra cámara o apagarla aquí
tenemos nuestro botón de disparo que es
nuestro botón más importante vamos a
cablear lo de la misma forma que cable
amos nuestro botón de encendido pelamos
nuestros cables magnéticos los
enrollamos alrededor de nuestros cables
de conexión de calibre 22 los soldados
en su lugar ponemos plástico que se
encoge encima de dichos cables cortamos
cualquier exceso de los tubos de
plástico y usamos nuestra pistola de
aire caliente para encoger el plástico
para proteger nuestras conexiones y los
conectamos igual en el emisor y
recolector del transistor y ahora
podemos controlar nuestra cámara con
nuestro arduino